une première depuis 2009 villepreux
organisait ce dimanche 25 juin son
triathlon dans les espaces verts de la
commune
la compétition a réuni plus de 120
athlètes novices ou spécialistes de la
discipline
l'objectif c'est s'amuser cc du vtt en
plus pourquoi faire pourquoi pas faire
une bonne place aux au classement
général on verra ce que ça donne
j'aime bien relever les défis et je
trais compétitrices donc voila c'était
un objectif de plus pour pouvoir
participer
pour cette nouvelle formule les
organisateurs avaient dessiné un
parcours au départ de la piscine alain
mimoun avec 400 m de natation 10 km de
vtt 4 km de course à pied ça se veut
vraiment j'allais dire familiale c'est
pas familial mais ça ça se veut un
parcours agréable on va dire donc voilà
c'est passé pas un parcours difficile
il ya quelques quelques côtes mais bon
voilà malgré tout même si c'est pas des
distances officiel il faut quand même
s'entraîner un minimum parce que bon
faut tenir sur la distance à l'arrivée
première réaction fatigué très fatigué
dans sa station en bas ça brûle de
partout là faut que ça j'aimerais bien
préféré finir par la piscine mais c'est
pas on les prend une bonne douche
sensation fatigué c'est finalement le
versailles et guillaume henry qui
remporte le contre la montre avec un
taux inférieur à 45 minutes
le triathlète licencié à versailles
réalisé plus de 28 km heure de moyenne
en vtt
vu qu'on partait sous forme de contre la
montre a pas de stratégie particulière
je sais que mon plus dangereux
concurrent c'était aussi un gars de
versailles qui partait à 8 minutes après
fallait que je donne tout le temps le
sportif tentera de défendre son encore
l'année prochaine une nouvelle édition
devrait être programmée pour l'été 2010